[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
consacré à la situation en Iran alors
que le procureur de la République
islamique a évoqué la relation
l'abolition de la police des mœurs cette
police responsable de l'arrestation et
de l'assassinat de Marsa à minuit cette
annonce semble être une victoire pour
les femmes iraniennes et pourtant pour
l'instant la loi ne change pas le voile
reste obligatoire et les forces de
l'ordre doivent le faire respecter ce
lundi un nouvel appel à la grève pendant
trois jours à entraîner des fermetures
de magasins dans plusieurs villes
iraniennes la mobilisation se poursuit
donc notamment à Ispahan et dans la
région kurde de l'Iran alors comment
interpréter les propos du procureur sur
l'abolition de la police des mœurs
sont-ils révélateurs de failles au sein
du pouvoir malgré la répression quelle
est la mobilisation après l'appel à la
grève pendant trois jours dans le pays
est-ce un tournant finalement dans le
bras de fer entre la population
iranienne et le pouvoir et bien on en
discute avec mes réalité j'ai plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés Adèle bakawan
bonsoir vous êtes franco-irania il y
aura qui en pardon kurde directeur du
centre de recherche français sur l'Irak
merci d'être avec nous et bienvenue en
face de vous nous avons au Soro kasmae
bonsoir vous êtes romancière et éditrice
Franco iranienne directrice de la
collection horizon persan consacrée au
littérature iranienne et afghane c'est
aux éditions Actes Sud auteur de ennemi
de Dieu ça c'est chez Robert Laffont et
de un jour avant la fin du monde
toujours chez Robert Laffont et
bienvenue à vous
également avec nous Adek Yann bonsoir
vous êtes professeur de sociologie
politique à l'Université de Paris Cité
je vais également citer votre livre
femme et pouvoir en Islam c'est chez
Michalon bienvenue à vous en face de
vous Adrien Goby bonsoir
bonsoir de Seine-et-Marne vous êtes à
l'initiative d'une résolution d'ailleurs
que vous nous avez apporté ce soir
résolution voter lundi dernier à
l'Assemblée nationale à l'unanimité
résolution qui condamne bien sûr le
régime iranien qui soutient le peuple
iranien en condamnant notamment la
restriction des libertés des droits et
des droits des femmes bienvenue à sur ce
bienvenue dans le débat pardon avant
notre discussion j'aimerais revenir
d'abord sur les faits en images le
procureur donc de la République
islamique a évoqué hier l'abolition de
la police des mœurs quelle est d'abord
la portée de cette déclaration les
moments de réponse avec Étienne papono
Téhéran 2019 une foule s'interpose pour
empêcher l'arrestation d'une femme non
voilée par la police des mœurs des
vidéos d'accrochage avec la patrouille
d'orientation son nom officiel en Iran
tourne par dizaines sur internet depuis
des années mais en septembre dernier le
décès de Marsa a mis arrêté pour un
voile mal porté déclenche un mouvement
de contestation d'une ampleur inédite
rebondissements dimanche lorsque le
procureur général iranien annonce la
dissolution de cette police la veille ce
même procureur disait qu'une réforme de
la loi de 1983 sur le port du voile
obligatoire est en cours sans plus de
précision ces annonces suscitent le
scepticisme des Iraniens exilé au
Kurdistan irakien
le régime iranien c'est très bien qu'il
vit ces derniers jours et qu'il est sur
le point de tomber il fait tout ce qu'il
peut pour survivre plus longtemps et
c'est très bien que si l'obligation du
port du voile suiviste il est voué à
disparaître cette décision vise à
influencer l'opinion publique
l'intérieur ministère de tutelle de la
police des mœurs n'a pas confirmé la
dissolution de quoi laisser craindre un
jeu de dupe du pouvoir c'est ce
qu'affirme plusieurs iraniens sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment la journaliste
et militante Massy alinéjade pour elle
cette annonce visa stoppée le mouvement
de contestation de leur côté les
manifestants ont appelé à une grève de
trois jours cette semaine pour accentuer
la pression sur le régime
donc la portée de cette annonce en fait
de cette évocation par le procureur sur
cette abolition ou pas de la police des
mœurs côté de toute façon on sait que
les Iraniennes les Iraniens d'ailleurs
qui manifestent maintenant depuis plus
de 3 mois on largement dépassé la
problématique du voile on sait que le
mouvement s'est étendu et que le
revendication aujourd'hui sont pour leur
renversement du régime et non plus
seulement pour le voile enfin une
abolition de la police des mœurs ça
serait une sacrée étape non ben écoutez
justement la police est morte n'a pas
été abolie mais il faut dire que le
avant 2007 parce que la police ne meurt
ça a été créée en 2007 par amadina le
président populiste mais avant la police
est mort c'est il y avait d'autres
structures qui est également veillées à
ce que les femmes respectent les
préceptes vestimentaires islamiques et
donc l'abolition de la police demeure ce
qui est effectivement mise à l'index
pour l'assassinat de enfin après
l'assassinat de Gina Massa Amin et bien
devait en fait
être aboli mais remplacer par une autre
structure donc effectivement c'est que
ce soit on nous dit quand même a priori
il y a une abolition donc telle que la
annoncé procureur mais ça serait
remplacé par un autre type un autre
structure et que de toute façon la loi
qui oblige les femmes à porter le voile
reste en vigueur restera en vigueur
parce que le voile obligatoire c'est
vraiment le fondement idéologique de ce
régime et donc la répression a continué
aussi donc moi je comprends pas pourquoi
on doit donner beaucoup plus beaucoup de
poids à cette annonce là même si ça
verrait vrai ce qui n'est pas le cas
parce que le mystère de l'Intérieur ne
l'a pas confirmé ni le gouvernement
d'ailleurs
vous êtes vous êtes d'accord est-ce que
vous-même ça serait une étape si
effectivement cette police des mœurs
était abolie est-ce que il y a donc vous
êtes d'accord avec ce que je viens de
dire justement
je suis tout à fait d'accord que
désormais les revendications de ce
mouvement de contestation dépasse
largement à la question du voile mais le
fait le fait d'annoncer même si ce n'est
pas encore tout à fait confirmé cette
nouvelle là c'est un indicateur à
prendre en compte c'est un indicateur
qui démontre qui met en scène la
fragilité d'un régime le régime est
fragile le régime se sent menacé
récemment là il y a trois jours il y a
eu une grande réunion entre les les
représentants de pastaran c'est-à-dire
les gardiens de de régime à Bagdad à
Bagdad avec l'autorité iranienne et
l'autorité de GRK par rapport justement
à cette question là j'ai discuté
directement je suis une phrase avec les
la délégation irakienne on nous dit
clairement que le régime a peur pour la
première fois ce régime a peur pourquoi
parce que toutes les stratégies mises en
place le régime par rapport à ce
mouvement de contestation ont échoué et
là ils savent pas quoi faire et donc le
fait annoncer qu'ils vont déçoit dans
cette police de mars c'est un indicateur
à prendre en compte donc c'est un recul
vous pensez écoutez-moi je pense que
bien sûr le régime est fragilisé bien
sûr le régime a peur de ce mouvement qui
prend chaque jour plus d'ampleur mais je
pense que c'est un effet d'annonce qu'il
faut décrypter à Londres donc de ces
trois jours de de grève et de
manifestations aujourd'hui demain et
après-demain le 5 le 6 le 7
l'information véritable c'est ça c'est
qu'il y a trois jours de grève générale
de mobilisation générale qui va finir le
7 décembre par la journée de l'étudiant
donc ça sera mercredi ça sera mercredi
donc c'est très important et je pense
que c'est un leurre que le régime a
voulu si vous voulez intervenir dans le
monde médiatique pour un petit peu
passer faire passer au deuxième plan
l'information principale qui est les
trois jours de mobilisation il veut
faire diversion
ça n'a pas été confirmé ça a été juste
un effet d'annonce oralement et il y a
aucun aucun décret aucun
communiqué même alors justement notre
correspondant à Téhéran lui dit que le
porte-parole du comité chargé de
l'ordonnance du bien et de
l'interdiction du mal qui comprend donc
les Miss de l'intérieur des
renseignements et d'autres responsables
à confirmer selon les médias iraniens la
dissolution de la police des morts voilà
une réaction dans le prolongement de ce
qui a été dit je pense qu'il faut faire
preuve d'une grande prudence parce que
il est vrai que le procureur général a
fait cette annonce qui derrière n'a pas
été suivi des faits aucun responsable de
la République islamique d'Iran n'a
souhaité aborder le sujet c'est comme si
pour que les Français nous comprennent
bien c'est comme si en plus Éric
Dupond-Moretti parlait de quelque chose
qui relève des compétences du ministre
de l'Intérieur donc il n'a pas vocation
à s'exprimer sur ce sujet donc je pense
qu'il faut faire preuve d'une grande
prudence et ne pas oublier comme ça a
été dit précédemment qu'aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de lois liberticides qui
existent en Iran et qui demeure il faut
peut-être revenir sur la structure de ce
régime donc là effectivement il s'agit
du pouvoir judiciaire et de l'autre côté
cette police des mœurs ne relève pas en
fait du pouvoir judiciaire le pouvoir
judiciaire reste ce qu'il est donc il y
a abolition ou pas de la police des
mœurs effectivement ça ne change pas le
côté répressif du régime c'est ce que
vous disiez et d'ailleurs le alors
justement le procureur et le pouvoir
judiciaire long tout de suite aussi
confirmé en disant de toute façon on va
pas tolérer les femmes non voilées au
mal voilées on va continuer à voilà à
réprimer en l'occurrence donc qu'est-ce
que ça change mais en même temps ces
éléments de langage pardonnez-moi ça
veut dire quand même quelque chose
est-ce que est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
un petit peu à ce que dit Monsieur
là-dessus sur peut-être une sorte de
message de difficulté c'est ce que j'ai
dit hier en entendant cette information
c'était des petits gages
au mieux si c'est confirmé ça sera des
petits gages donner justement aux
manifestants afin de les calmer pourquoi
parce que comme ça a été dit par sur le
casse maille les trois jours aujourd'hui
elle est toujours à venir vont être
vraiment décisives on sait que la grève
de des commerçants des ouvriers des
étudiants et très bien suivi il y a pas
que haïsme on va y revenir après il y a
dans plusieurs villes et en même temps
en même temps les étudiants vont
certainement s'organiser se mobiliser
mercredi donc c'est pour divertir
l'opinion à la fois iranienne et
internationale de dire on va abolir
abolir c'est trop tard de toute façon
c'est une décision qui aurait dû être
prise il y a trois mois de ça vous dites
c'est trop tard pourquoi parce que les
femmes ne sont déjà plus le voile a déjà
dépassé parce que n'ont pas porter le
voile c'est un acquis pour beaucoup de
femmes iraniennes donc qu'il abolissent
ou non qu'est-ce que ça change et que la
communications sont pour leur
renversement du régime aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs c'est moi je voulais dire je
voulais juste dire je suis tout à fait
d'accord que même si on abolie cette
police là ça va pas changer grand chose
la question n'est pas là la question
pourquoi maintenant le régime parle de
de l'évolution de cette police alors
bien évidemment on peut avoir cette
grille de lecture pour dire pour faire
la diversion avec le mouvement de
contestation et avec la communauté
internationale ça c'est possible cela
est tout à fait possible diversion
mais en même temps pour moi en
observateur c'est très important
pourquoi c'est très important parce que
tout c'est la première fois que le
régime envoie même si ce n'est que la
diversion en signale un signe c'est pour
moi ce signe c'est le signe d'un
mouvement de contestation qui monte en
puissance à qui fait peur nous miroir
numéro 12 un régime malgré tout
fragilisé et un régime fragilisé qui
cède même si ce n'est que la diversion
de toute façon le monde parle de cette
de cette indicateur le fait que le monde
parle de cet indicateur c'est-à-dire il
met en visibilité d'un régime
qui s'aide qui cède même si c'est tout
ils ont continué à réprimer ils ont
continué à exécuter bien sûr ils vont
continuer à arrêter il continue à
arrêter les actrices qui n'ont fait que
poster des vidéos sans le vrai sur
Instagram elle a été donc elle a été
arrêtée ce matin pour une vidéo postée
hier donc le régime n'a pas vraiment
cédé l'important c'est la loi de du port
obligatoire du voile elle est la loi est
toujours là la loi est toujours là et la
loi et la base idéologique le fondement
idéologique de ce régime jamais le
régime si le régime abolith le port
obligatoire du voile on peut dire que il
y a plus de république islamique parce
que remédie dès le premier jour où il
est venu au pouvoir il a focalisé
le corps de la femme et la toute
première loi qui a été donc votée prise
donc par la République islamique c'était
la loi sur le port de obligatoire du
voile islamique donc oui la loi sur le
l'obligation du port du voile n'est
absolument pas remise en question non
mais en réalité on le voit depuis le
début du mouvement de contestation qu'on
peut qualifier de révolutionnaire en
Iran ce n'est pas la seule question du
voile et du port obligatoire du voile
dans la sphère publique qui est visée
aujourd'hui par les Iraniens et les
Iraniens tout à fait d'accord avec ce
qui a été dit précédemment aujourd'hui
c'est un acquis pour de nombreuses
femmes dans de nombreuses villes
aujourd'hui c'est
l'institutionnalisation de l'inégalité
entre les sexes et
l'institutionnalisation du non-respect
de la dignité et des droits humains qui
est visé par les Iraniens et les
Iraniens or la République islamique
d'Iran c'est bâti sur un certain nombre
de préceptes qui prévoit notamment que
la parole de la femme ne vaut que 50% de
la parole d'un homme donc vous voyez
bien que c'est tout c'était difficile là
qui aujourd'hui viser par la
contestation populaire et comme ça a été
dit précédemment la répression continue
je ne sais pas si c'est une diversion ou
non mais en tous les cas c'est une
information
que c'est une fake news comme j'ai pu le
lire les médias dans tous les cas
doivent prendre cette information avec
prudence c'est ce qui n'a pas été fait
il faut bien le dire depuis 24 heures
est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est jusqu'à
une fake news de dire qu'il y a eu une
déclaration
abolir cette police des morts fake news
je suis pas sûr parce que fake news
c'est qu'on le fait délibérément je
regardais les journaux iraniens et qui
avait titré finalement le la polystère
était abolie ou non c'est que même pour
les journaux iraniens les journalistes
iraniens de l'Iran la question était
très floue c'est-à-dire ça n'a pas été
vraiment confirmé ni infirmé
en tout cas
je vais vous dire que c'était déjà en
débat c'est-à-dire que depuis
l'assassinat de Gina Massa mini la
question est en débat et donc il
n'arrive pas à se mettre d'accord c'est
ça aussi qui se passe c'est-à-dire que
c'est s'il y a un petit signe ce petit
signe c'est probablement la dissension
existante entre les ultra conservateur
au pouvoir qui voilà qui qui tente un
petit peu de calmer la colère et cherche
en donnant quelque chose donnant dégage
comme comme je viens de dire mais ça va
pas marcher ça va pas fonctionner moi je
dis enfin d'une manière vraiment claire
et nette
le fait que le régime
mais sur la scène publique
un tel débat et soudé voile et dévoile
un tel débat c'est que désormais le
mouvement du contestation peut espérer
un peu plus voir jusqu'à aller le
changement du régime le régime jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il n'a fait que réprimer et
réprimer sans retenue d'une manière
brutale
même bombardé l'opposition kurde autour
des gens avec les drones et des missiles
balistiques n'est-ce pas il est allé
jusqu'à là on parle dans certaines zones
on parle de l'utilisation des armes
chimiques mais je voulais dire rien
n'empêche ce régime à passer à à une
répression beaucoup plus radicale mais
aujourd'hui le fait que ce régime
dévoile en tel débat c'est que le
changement est possible et ça veut dire
qu'il y a des bas effectivement où ça
même exclu la répression vous savez
c'est des tactiques le régime emploie
mais il faut je pense qu'il faut prendre
le rapport de force dans l'autre sens
c'est pas parce que
petite mesurette même si quand bien même
elle serait avait juste ou réelle était
annoncé que les manifestants ont
l'espoir de changer quelque chose
l'espoir est déjà dans les
manifestations les femmes qui
manifestent ont déjà abolé leur voile
ils l'ont jeté au feu et il y a plein de
femmes qui se baladent dans les rues de
Téhéran et en province sans le voile et
ça commence à devenir un acquis de ces
manifestations même si côté manifestant
mais ce n'est pas du tout anaki côté
régime c'est ça
parler de l'espoir par rapport à cette
mesure l'espoir est là parce que il y a
donc je répète encore que il faut voir
ça dans le contexte de ces trois
journées ça c'est très très important
parce que là on est en train depuis un
quart d'heure de discuter de cette
mesure alors qu'on aurait pu parler de
l'ampleur de cette demi-heure pour en
parler justement parce que c'est la
deuxième partie de ces débats je vous
rappelle les chiffres de la répression
qui a fait d'après l'une des ONG les
plus influentes enfin en tout cas les
plus renseignés 448 morts déjà dont 60
enfants et il y a six manifestants
d'après les chiffres qui ont été
condamnés à mort mais la Bolivie la
mobilisation continue et continue donc
après cet appel à la grève notamment à
Ispahan mais pas seulement vous nous
direz où mais aussi d'ailleurs dans la
région kurde de l'Iran on fait d'abord
un point en images avec Noémie roche
pas une seule boutique ouverte dans le
quartier historique de la grande ville
dispaant
même chose ici au cœur du Kurdistan
iranien
dont ces régions où la contestation
contre le régime est importante l'appel
à la grève est visiblement suivie mais
ce n'est pas représentatif de l'ensemble
du pays
par les jeunes par les étudiants et ces
traités n'a pas un soutien très très
vaste dans l'ensemble de pays les gens
de la classe moyenne ou petite
mais la petite bourgeoisie ça veut dire
le bazar l'ensemble de ces populations
n'adhère pas en fait à ce mouvement le
bazar à Téhéran c'est dans ce quartier
que se trouve notamment le grand bazar
c'est ensemble de ruelles où se
succèdent boutique et eshop un quartier
conservateur ici les commerçants les
Bazaris appartiennent au couche
traditionnelles de la société iranienne
ils sont réputés proches des mots là et
du clergé et donc du régime iranien or
même ici des boutiques sont confirmer ce
lundi alors faut-il y voir un signe de
solidarité des Bazaris avec le mouvement
de protestation difficile à dire selon
ce sociologue on est dans l'un des
terminations à ce sujet ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il y a des motifs extrêmement
sérieux de mécontentement de la part des
commerçants du bazar avec une situation
économique régressive des grévistes que
le régime iranien fait tout pour
décourager entre menaces d'amende
annonce d'exécution des manifestants
condamnés à mort et policiers
anti-émeutes déployant nombre dans la
capitale
je voyais effectivement être totalement
en désaccord avec le fait qu'il y aura
une faible mobilisation au fameux bazar
de Téhéran on n'a pas eu vraiment
d'informations donc quel est est-ce que
vous vous avez des informations sur la
mobilisation au sein de ce bazar on a vu
effectivement les images à Ispahan là
vraiment les boutiques sont fermées on a
vu également des images dans les régions
Kurdes iranienne mais pas justement au
bazar de Téhéran alors est-ce que
pardon le bazar de Téhéran il y a
certains commerces qui sont restés
fermés les forces de l'ordre sont
arrivés ont essayé parce que les
commerçants étaient là aussi à trouver
pour protester et donc ils ont été
menacés les commerçants ont été menacés
de d'ouvrir leur commerce mais ils l'ont
refusé après à cela s'ajoute dans la
ville de Chiraz c'est il y a enfin il y
a énormément de villes moi j'en ai
compté une vingtaine de villes moyennes
et grandes y compris à machad la ville
sainte ou les commerces étaient restés
fermés et ça c'est vraiment important
pourquoi est-ce que les commerçants avec
ont malgré leurs liens historique avec
le clergé répondent positivement à ce
mot d'ordre de grève aujourd'hui et
aussi la dernière fois donc oui ils sont
touchés économiquement et financièrement
comme tous les autres iraniens mais le
fait de répondre positivement à cet
appel de grève aux côtés les ouvriers
nous n'oublions pas aux côtés des bien
sûr enseignants des étudiants et
d'autres catégories sociales ça veut
dire que le nom de mécontentements de
mécontents est très important et je
voudrais si vous permettez je citer un
rapport qui a été dévoilé récemment et
qui montre que selon un sondage de
régime
87% des Iraniens s'identifient avec le
mouvement actuel donc ne dites pas que
les Iraniens ne sont pas d'accord les
erreurs sont d'accord sauf que tout le
monde ne descend pas dans la rue
parce que vous risquez de vous faire
tuer 64 enfants se sont fait tuer parce
que il accompagnait leur leurs parents
et donc de toute façon on fait on fait
la grève moi je sais que les Iraniens
jusqu'à hier et ceux qui le pouvaient
financièrement était en train de
d'acheter de quoi manger pendant trois
jours à quel point ils étaient sûrs que
la grève allait être suivie donc tout le
monde alors même quand je vois l'image
des femmes balouchoir j'ai travaillé au
paludisme les femmes balouches qui
sortaient même pas de chez elle sans
être accompagné par leur mari et qui
aujourd'hui manifeste dans les rues
certes avec leur voile mais qui disent
avec ou sans voile sans régime doit
partir qu'est-ce que vous voulez de plus
pour moi ça montre que cette société
dans sa grande majorité et pour le
renversement de ce régime cette
mobilisation en tout cas est forte on a
vu dans la région kurde iranienne et
aujourd'hui c'est également le cas oui
absolument c'est là la force de ce
mouvement de contestation lorsque je
compare ce mouvement avec par exemple le
mouvement de contestation au Liban ou on
ira quand on a eu en 2019 la force c'est
quoi c'est que le régime a échoué à
itiser le mouvement de dire c'est un
mouvement des Kurdes contre les Perses
ou confessionnaliser le mouvement dire
c'est un mouvement sunnite contre les
chiites non tout cette politique a
échoué pourquoi parce que tout
simplement le cure qui participe
retrouve-moi de contestation ni
participent pas autant que kurde mais
autant que iranien l'arabe ou le Belge
ou le perse autrement dit aujourd'hui on
a un référentiel national iranien autour
duquel tout le monde s'identifie par
exemple le Massa Amini c'est une fille
et kurde mais elle est devenue leur
référentiel de tous les Iraniens
désormais c'est une identité de ce
mouvement de contestation c'est pour
dire parce que le mouvement est national
et parce que le mouvement couvre la
totalité du territoire national il fait
peur sourire
est-ce que effectivement la population a
Téhéran se mobilise un peu moins par
exemple que dans des régions comme la
région kurde ça dépend des jours on a eu
une forte mobilisation dans les écoles
dans les lycées dans les universités
dans les quartiers d'ailleurs il y a
tous les tous les deux trois jours il y
a un appel à manifester par les jeunes
des quartiers de Téhéran ainsi que dans
toutes les villes et il y a le soir par
la fenêtre etc mais moi je voudrais
revenir sur cet aspect là donc la grève
du bazar bien sûr il y a la grève des
ouvriers le métallurgie du pétrole ainsi
que dans plusieurs Escal est vraiment
massive cette grève au sein justement
pétrolier parce que là ça voudrait dire
que c'est une étape extrêmement
importante
qui est vécu la révolution de 709
c'était emblématique la grève du bazar
quand le bazar donc
baisser les rideaux ça c'était vraiment
une étape supérieure de cette révolution
là et puis il y avait la grève des
ouvriers j'ai l'impression de revivre
mais ça prend du temps tout n'arrive pas
au même moment bien sûr
tout le monde a donc parlé de la peur
qui a enfin de de la
comment dire la férocité de la question
qu'il y a il y a 18000 vous avez donné
des statistiques il y a 18 000
arrestations et donc quand on dit
arrestation cela veut dire des
conditions de
d'emprisonnement totalement enfin les
gens sont torturés on les on les force à
des aveux sous torture et ils sont
blessés sans aucun soin médical etc donc
il faut aussi les femmes violées et les
femmes exactement et il y a une jeune
femme qui a été donc avant-hier libérée
sous caution elle avait deux cocards
énormes maintenant ils veulent même pas
cacher donc au contraire ils veulent
montrer pour faire peur mais je pense
que dès le début la peur a changé de
donc de camp mais malgré tout la
répression effectivement on dit cela
d'un certain nombre
je voudrais juste ajouter quelque chose
moi aussi j'ai vécu la révolution de 79
et ce que je voyais c'est que c'est la
relation 70 ans atterrant c'est là que
ça se passait surtout c'était de l'Est
ou à l'ouest non de Sud quartier
populaire vers le nord quartier riche
d'accord et quand on a les vers les
quartiers riches il se passait mais rien
de tout mais personne était dans la rue
etc donc quand on ne voit pas les gens
dans la rue ça ne vaut pas dire que les
gens sont d'accord avec le régime et
contre le mouvement et surtout
aujourd'hui encore une fois la
répression est vraiment féroce donc
raison pour laquelle les gens
réfléchissent deux fois avant de
descendre la rue mais montre leur
mécontentement
par d'autres moyens dont la grève dont
la grève Adrien Gomez que peut faire
finalement la communauté internationale
puisque vous êtes à l'origine de cette
résolution qui a été votée à l'unanimité
à l'Assemblée nationale en France il
faut continuer à agir comme on l'a fait
vous le dites avec le vote à l'unanimité
de la résolution il faut continuer
d'agir sur la scène internationale
internationale
et vous savez la portée symbolique alors
il y a ça n'a pas force de loi une
proposition de résolution mais ça a plus
qu'une force symbolique à une force
politique et on le voit aujourd'hui on
l'a vu d'ailleurs avec la convocation
dernièrement de l'ambassadeur de France
en Iran les propositions suite au vote
de cette résolution on le voit aussi
avec les propos qui sont tenus par le
président Macron qui dit clairement que
l'Iran la République islamique d'Iran
raconte n'importe quoi sur les 7
otages qui sont aujourd'hui détenus
arbitrairement par le régime iranien
après vous le disiez que des aveux leur
ait été extirpé de force donc on voit
qu'aujourd'hui la communauté
internationale la mobilisation ça embête
véritablement le régime qui ne parvient
ni à mesurer en interne si j'ose dire la
force de la mobilisation et des
personnes qui malgré les peines encourus
se mobilisent chaque jour dans les rues
en Iran et de l'autre la pression
internationale qui s'intensifie c'est
une très bonne chose il faut continuer
si je voulais aussi revenir sur les
peines de mort donc quand les
manifestants arrêtez vous savez on a une
dizaine de jeunes dont certains moins de
17 ans qui ont été donc condamnés à mort
récemment et leur vie est vraiment en
danger c'est pour ça aussi c'est une des
si vous voulez des dimensions d'une
simple arrestation lors d'une
manifestation c'est important et vous
verrez quand même vous réagissez sur
c'est important la mobilisation avec de
la communauté internationale y compris
quand c'est symbolique comme absolument
même quand c'est symbolique et moi je
pense que ces résolutions servent aussi
à avertir les pays qui soutiennent
encore aujourd'hui l'Iran y compris les
pays asiatiques avec lesquels l'Iran
fait du commerce etc y compris même la
Chine qui est qui n'est pas un exemple
de la démocratie mais ces pays-là l'Inde
la Malaisie et l'Indonésie etc et et
voilà et les pays de la région sont
quand même conscientes maintenant que la
communauté internationale ou en tout cas
la démocratie
occidentale et bien sont mobilisés
contre le régime iranien et d'ailleurs à
cela s'ajoute et je termine là même il
me semble que même les Chinois vous
savez que les chiens les Chinois ont
signé il y a deux ans de ça un contrat
sur de 25 ans avec l'Iran et il refuse
maintenant de mettre en application le
contrat c'est à dire elle est investir
en Iran dans le champ pétrolier et
gazier donc parce qu'ils ne sont pas
sûrs de ce qui va se passer est-ce que
ce régime va rester en place ou non donc
il y a tout ça
c'est même les Chinois et quand même
absolument une incertitude compte à la
longévité de ce régime et je pense que
c'est effectivement très important mais
en même temps la communauté
internationale je voulais dire un petit
mot
on est dans la Turquie l'Iran pour la
Turquie c'est vrai on pourrait en faire
comme on en discuter parce que c'est un
état considéré comme partenaire
respectable acceptable par contre la
République islamique de l'Iran est
considéré comme un état voyou
j'estime la réaction de la communauté
internationale doit chantonne à Paris
est une réaction très très timide là on
voit une répression radicale sauvage des
centaines de jeunes tués massacrés des
prisonniers etc je pense beaucoup de
déclarations le mouvement de
contestation je voulais juste terminer
le mouvement de contestation est
vraiment menacé par une répression
beaucoup plus radicale aujourd'hui selon
moi c'est très bien les déclarations
Washington Paris Londres mais par contre
il faut un moment donné aller à adopter
ce que j'appelle le droit à la
protection sans sans cette souffrance
tout ce qu'on a fait pour les Kurdes
d'Irak dans les années 90 on a protégé
ce peuple contre la barbarie de Saddam
Hussein il faut absolument que je ne dis
pas appliquer exactement le même modèle
mais réfléchir à protéger comment
protéger un mouvement totalement
démocratique il n'y a aucune format un
mouvement civile qui s'exprime d'une
manière civilisée face à un régime qui
tue sans aucune aucune retenue dans ce
cas là la communauté internationale doit
assumer sa responsabilité comment
comment justement il faut réfléchir
comment mais l'objectif doit rester le
même c'est-à-dire protéger le mouvement
par n'importe quelle forme l'Irak nous
fait peur me fait peur ne parlez pas
nous nous parlez pas de l'Irak
mais je sais mais ni de l'intervention
des Américains et des autres en Irak
nous on veut pas ça en Iran comme vous
voulez protéger le mouvement
productive comment vous voulez protéger
le mouvement face à un régime
international doit être respecté et le
principe de non ingérence et en quelque
sorte sacralisée mais mais je l'ai pas
entendu dans les propos qui ont été
tenus précédemment depuis la livraison
par la République islamique d'Iran d'un
certain nombre de drones à la Russie il
y a une première vague de sanction du
Conseil de l'Europe ensuite ces a été
renforcée en le mois dernier puisque une
trentaine de dignitaires iraniens ont
été visées par des sanctions très
précises de la part des 27 pays de
l'Union européenne l'interdiction de
voyager dans le territoire de l'Union
Européenne et aussi le gel de tous les
avoir qui sont nombreux je peux vous le
dire dans les pays des 27 tout ça ça a
été fait en accord avec les Canadiens
les Britanniques et les Américains donc
on peut pas dire que rien n'est fait il
y a des choses concrètes au-delà des
déclarations de principes qui sont
néanmoins importantes je pense qu'on
minimise on a souvent tendance en France
à minimiser la portée symbolique des
prises de décision et des prises de
position comme des responsables
diplomatiques concrète vous avez un
mouvement
démocratique qui n'a pas des armes en
face vous avez un régime
armé lourdement et qui utilise toutes
les armes y compris des missiles y
compris des drones contre ce mouvement
de contestation comment vous allez
protéger de la mort la mort la mort
le mouvement de contestation c'est
malheureusement il y a pas de solution
miracle malheureusement il y a des
milliers de morts dans la rue de Téhéran
comment vous allez faire qu'est-ce que
vous moi je propose que cette communauté
cette communauté internationale à un
devoir à protéger les mouvements
démocratiques dans le monde je dis pas
une intervention je dis pas une
occupation je demande pas aux États-Unis
ou de l'Europe envoyer des armées mais
je dis la communauté internationale à
l'obligation juridique morale éthique
etc des responsables de mettre en place
tous les médicaments
demande le rappel de des ambassadeurs
européens en Europe ou leur envoient des
ambassadeurs de la République islamique
partout dans le monde il y a de ce genre
de mesure mais une intervention
étrangère en
iraniens
vous parlez de protection mais qui va
est-ce qu'on va envoyer
les casques bleus de l'ONU pour protéger
la commission de droits de l'homme de
l'ONU en tout cas à diligenter une
enquête alors par exemple lorsqu'elle
dirigeante une enquête est-ce qu'elle a
le pouvoir effectivement en tout cas de
faire déjà d'aller enquêter sur place
les autorités iraniennes ont dit non on
n'accepte pas que les étrangers viennent
enquêter ici on va le faire nous même et
aucun protestataire ne pourra participer
à la commission d'enquête donc c'est une
commission d'enquête par le pour le
régime qu'est-ce que vous proposez
est-ce que vous proposez que la
communauté internationale assistée
je propose que ça fait 40 ans nous
étions face à une certaine indifférence
de la communauté internationale par
exemple nous on se souvient à chaque
fois qu'on avait des manifestations pour
protester contre ce qui se passait en
Iran on était une cinquantaine de
personnes là le mouvement femme de
liberté a changé la donne à changer cet
état d'esprit c'est-à-dire les Européens
les le monde entier a compris qu'en Iran
il y a une forte mobilisation est
différent il y a un mouvement
démocratique qui est totalement
différent de la révolution de 79 qui
n'avait pas beaucoup d'aspects
démocratique et qui était incarné par un
chef religieux qui était remis là on n'a
pas à cette espèce de de
personnes titulaires de de de oui mais
alors le paradox enfin le paradoxe
entre le régime et la population le fait
qu'il y ait pas d'incarnation qui est
pas comment en fait le faire basculer si
vous n'avez pas d'incarnation je
voudrais juste ajouter à ce qui est à ce
qui vient d'être dit deux éléments c'est
un mouvement répandu des personnes qui
sont modernes et là ils disaient contre
l'islam politique donc ça c'est vraiment
important et la communauté
internationale commence à se rendre
compte qu'il faut soutenir ce mouvement
après le après effectivement il y a pas
de chef mais on n'en veut pas nous dire
on le chef qui a été décidé par contre
David et les Occidentaux c'était roméini
donc les Iraniens d'aujourd'hui n'en
veut n'en veulent plus mais je vais vous
dire il y a en Iran et c'est ça existe
des conseils des conseils au sein des
ouvriers au sein des enseignants au sein
des étudiants au sein de commerçants etc
et des conseils de quartier et ça c'est
ces conseils là qui coordonnent par
exemple le mot d'ordre de grève et qui
voilà qui qui est suivi mais ça va
suffire justement c'est donc ces
conseils là il y a à cela s'ajoute des
personnalités que qu'on connaît que tout
le monde connaît et qui sont de
d'envergure même international qui sont
soit en résidence surveillée soit en
prisonnier etc et qui peuvent
effectivement le moment venu devenir un
conseil pour diriger son mouvement
compris des personnalités à l'étranger
non je parlais de des personnes qui sont
en ligne et qui sont en résidence
surveiller des personnes qui sont en
Iran et qui sont non pas du tout il y a
pas l'opposition iranienne à l'étranger
n'a absolument à mon sens aucune aucun
avenir moi j'aimerais ajouter aussi
l'aspect horizontal de ce mouvement donc
ce que souligner c'est au fait c'est ça
c'est à dire que c'est un mouvement
horizontal qui n'a peut-être pas
leader reconnu mais qui a des leaders au
sein de de ce mouvement qui est
d'ailleurs regardez tout ce qui s'est
passé depuis trois mois ça vient de
l'intérieur de ce mouvement c'est un
mouvement totalement inventif très
moderne qui avance et donc qui a ses
propres structures qu'on ne voit
peut-être pas de l'extérieur parce qu'il
faut aussi se protéger contre la
répression etc mais pour l'instant il a
très très bien fonctionné et il a donc
le mot d'ordre c'est fin de vie liberté
ça vient de l'intérieur même si vous
attendez beaucoup de mobilisation qui
vient donc aujourd'hui demain et après
demain
en plus qui transcende les classes
sociales bien évidemment on peut
s'attendre à ce que les les
universitaires soient mobilisés ils
l'ont été notamment par le passé mais
voir aujourd'hui les commerçants qui
sont affiliés au régime qui sont souvent
proches des
ultras conservateurs de ce régime et
forcément les mêmes raisons est-ce que
c'est pour la liberté ou est-ce que
c'est pas pour des raisons économiques à
vrai dire ce que l'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il plus que les hautes
dignitaires du régime qui sarcoutent via
l'appareil répressif de la République
islamique sur des positions et
malheureusement pour eux aujourd'hui ils
ne tiennent plus rien voilà
une grande partie de l'économie du pays
comment vous faites pour faire juste si
vous me permettez rebondir sur ce qui a
été dit par rapport au leader souvent on
me pose la question par rapport à l'Iran
mais aussi par rapport au mouvement de
contestation au Moyen-Orient d'une
manière générale Liban l'Irak et on nous
dit c'est pas fonctionner
ça fonctionne
n'a pas été pour le coup pour pouvoir on
garde les mêmes je voulais juste dire
nous avons changé l'époque nous avons
changé l'augmente nous avons avec nos
grilles de lecture classiques lorsqu'on
avait un mouvement social avec des
leaders endinines à la tête du parti
communiste non on a changé son monde là
justement la force du mouvement de
contestation dans ces pays c'est qu'il
n'y a pas un leader lorsqu'on arrête le
leader tout est fini tout le monde à la
maison aujourd'hui vous des Massa il y a
des milliers massages dans la rue c'est
ça c'est là la force des mouvements de
contestation à la fois abeille route à
Bagdad et ce mouvement de contestation
en une chute du régime et à nouveau mais
un nouveau type de pouvoir répondre et
écoutez on est on est face à des forces
coercitions qui n'ont pas encore changé
de camp on est d'accord là-dessus mais
on les voit fatigué on les voit se poser
la question de savoir pourquoi tu es
pour maintenir un régime corrompu
dictatorial répressif c'est à dire que
ce sont des questions que un certain
nombre de ces forces coercitions sont en
train aussi de ce de s'opposer et donc
si ça continue si ce mouvement continue
ça fait trois mois que ça continue et
bien cela aura certainement des impacts
de plus en plus grandes sur les forces
coercition sur les militaires sur les
pasteurs ne sont pas unanime non plus
aller leur parler vous croyez que les
bases de pastaran sont profit de la
manne pétrolière bien sûr que non il y
en a qui sont idéologiquement où étaient
de logement se rapproche toujours régime
mais à force de voir la corruption la
répression etc il y en a qui
contesteraient donc cela bien sûr le
moment venu moi j'ai absolument aucun
doute là-dessus et donc qui vont changer
de camp comment on l'a vu d'ailleurs
aussi en 1979 qui le cru que le régime
du chat allait pouvoir tomber mais on
est on en est pas là c'est à dire on
n'est pas en train de dire que le régime
va être renversé du jour au lendemain
mais si le mouvement continue et je
pense que ces résolutions sont
importantes parce que ça donne vous
savez les Iraniens quand ils entendent
que l'Assemblée nationale en France a
fait cette résolution etc et qui va
faire pression de façon de notre sur le
régime islamique tyran ben ça les
encourage à continuer voyez donc ça
c'est aussi bien politique comme ça a
été dit que symbolique finalement
les signes de cette dépression dont
parle Z sont déjà visibles il y a eu un
enregistrement il y a quelques jours
d'une réunion donc des chefs de gardiens
de la révolution ou les gens
rapportaient
des troupes
disant que donc ils sont très
démoralisés et que ils passent des
heures à faire donc à faire le tour de
dans les rues et donc on soulignait les
propos de ramener disons il faut
peut-être faire procéder à des
augmentations de salaire peut-être leur
donner des prix voilà vous décrivez ils
sont un peu dépassés par les événements
en tout cas
moi je sais pas s'ils vont tout de suite
changer de camp mais ils sont en tout
cas
on continue au fur et à mesure que le
mois continue on peut s'attendre à des
fissures au sein même
à votre conclusion parce qu'on a plus le
temps la France peut-elle aller plus
loin et montrer sa solidarité il faut
une nouvelle vague de sanctions contre
les dignitaires Iraniens qui sont
responsables de la répression c'est ce
qu'on a fait le mois dernier il faut
intensifier je l'espère avant les fêtes
de fin d'année et puis il faut surtout
ne rien lâcher et ne pas céder au
chantage le président de la République
l'a clairement dit sur les votre sortie
sans français qui sont détenus
arbitrairement on ne doit pas lâcher ce
peuple incroyable qui se soulève
aujourd'hui courageusement au péril de
sa vie vous aviez raison de le dire
c'est quand même assez incroyable de se
dire 18000 arrestations d'iraniennes et
d'Iraniens dans le pays près de 500
morts plus d'une soixantaine d'enfants
donc aujourd'hui on doit nous et moi en
tant que responsable politique c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai présenté la
proposition de résolution on doit
soutenir très solennellement ce
mouvement révolutionnaire en Iran et je
vous prie aussi de parler des
18000 arrestations et des peines de
morts
pas seulement les 7
juste un petit mot je voulais dire
l'Iran est une grande puissance au
Moyen-Orient si jamais le régime change
c'est tout le Moyen-Orient qui change
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous en
tout cas one merci Adrien Gomis merci à
zadekian Merci à VOUS Soro kasmaï merci
à vous tous de nous avoir suivi reste
avec nous France 24